un bateau humanitaire empêché de
débarquer sur les côtes italiennes
voilà la sphère au coeur du procès qui
attend le leader de la ligue ce samedi
une décision attendue pour matteo
salvini celle de savoir si oui ou non il
sera traduit en justice l'ancien
ministre de l'intérieur est accusé
d'abus de pouvoir et de séquestration de
personne
l'affairé remonte à août 2019 plus de 80
migrants sont sauvés en mer par une ong
espagnole open arms alors que les
conditions de vie deviennent difficiles
à bord du navire
matteo salvini s'oppose fermement à
l'arrivée de ce dernier sur le sol
italien ministre de l'intérieur à
l'époque selvini a été auditionné une
première fois sur cette affaire en
janvier dernier il assure ne rien
regretter je suis absolument serein et
fier de ce que j'ai fait je suis juste
désolé pour le coût de ces procès
supporté par les contribuables italiens
et pour le temps que je fais perdre aux
magistrats finalement autorisé par un
procureur de 6 il a débarqué les 83
migrants parviennent à gagner la petite
île de lampedusa après 19 jours passés à
bord du bateau à l'origine de cette
opération
lorenzi espagnols affirment combattre
non seulement matteo salvini mais aussi
d'autres dirigeants européens
l'accusé aujourd'hui n'est pas seulement
monsieur salvini mais les gouvernements
italien et européen qui continue de
violer la convention de hambourg sur
l'obligation de secours en mer et celle
de genève sur l'interdiction de refuser
des réfugiés l'ancien ministre italien
de l'intérieur a déjà été mis en cause
dans une affaire similaire qui a eu lieu
également durant l'été 2010 9 salvini
avait alors bloqué le navire grégory
thil transportant 116 migrants en
décembre dernier le parquet sicilien de
catane a demandé l'abandon des
poursuites à son encontre